we just talked about ease of entry and
the joy of discovery and at PlayStation
we continue to develop and innovate
simple ways to access content
PlayStation now fueled by the power of
the network will provide our community
with access to our massive gaming
libraries starting with PlayStation 3
titles we have continued to tweak and
refine PS now since its initial beta
test and are proud to announce that the
service will be available in the United
States and Canada as an open beta on ps4
starting July 31st shortly after that PS
now will become available on ps3 and
PlayStation Vita as well
we also we also want to unlock our
library of games to those who still
don't own a Playstation device so later
this year we're bringing the PlayStation
now experience to select Sony
televisions if PS now is available in
your area all you need to do is get a
dual shock 3 and you're able to play our
vast catalogue of games
yeah that's pretty nervy during the open
beta PlayStation gamers will have access
to more than 100 ps3 games for the
industry's best publishers our own
worldwide studios as well as the best of
the indie development community in our
booth at e3 this week you can play such
major hits as Dead Space 3 God of War
ascension middle Gear Solid 5 Ground
zeroes Ratchet and Clank into the Nexus
and Ultra Street Fighter 4 will use the
open beta continue to listen to your
feedback and gather insights about your
experience with the service will also
work with our publishing partners to
test a range of rental durations and
prices we do look forward to hearing
from everyone who participates in the
beta as your voice will have a direct
impact on the development of our service
bringing PlayStation now to PlayStation
Vita is another example of our
commitment to the platform with PS now
Vita will have the best catalog of games
available on a mobile device and the
only mobile device with access to the
deep library of PlayStation games
innovation on Vita continues and its
integration with PlayStation 4 has
expanded the way gamers use the device
Remote Play gives Vita owners quick
access to ps4 games and the response has
been overwhelmingly positive with remote
play ps4 blockbusters such as Call of
Duty and Assassin's Creed will further
showcase PlayStation Vita as the
ultimate mobile platform in total there
are more than 100 Vita titles in
development today including tales of
hearts are from Namco
Ubisoft's beautifully hand-drawn RPG
child of light and Telltale's mash-up
with gearbox tales from Borderlands
minecraft is also coming to Vita and it
will be the full console experience with
co-op included you have two Minecraft
fans PSV that will remain a key pillar
for us and we look forward to sharing
more gaming experience across B the
dedicated titles PlayStation now and ps4
remote play a Tokyo Game Show last year
we announced another new console and the
outpouring of anticipation and
excitement was unprecedented as a result
we are now preparing to launch that
product in the United States Canada and
Europe starting this fall so let's talk
about PlayStation TV
this little gem will be able to pair
with your PlayStation 4 allowing you to
play your ps4 game via remote play on a
second television in your home it will
give you access to video and music
streaming services will give you the
ability to play hundreds of ps3 titles
made available through PlayStation now
and of course PlayStation TV will also
play most Vita titles as well as ps1 and
PSP classics in fact our Disney
partnership continues with Disney
infinity 2 coming to PlayStation TV and
PlayStation Vita early next year in
total that's nearly 1,000 games that
PlayStation TV owners will have access
to at launch PlayStation TV will be
available for $99 we will also offer a
bundle for $139 that will include a dual
shock 3 an 8 gigabyte memory card an
HDMI cable and a digital voucher for the
lego movie video game